oh okay so today you know what I was
thinking we could be fun to do okay I'm
a little scatterbrained sometimes
sometimes all the time yeah all the time
we should make what should be on your
wife resume
then we can make this together okay
gonna make one sure all right what
should what do you think should be on
someone's wife resume
uh well since I have a cooking channel
the first thing I would talk about is
meal preparation or cooking experience
meal prep for cooking experience okay
periods okay what else uh I think if
you're getting married you probably want
to have a family so I would talk about
your either babysitting or love for
children or anything that is uh your
experience around
um the little ones okay what about my
bag
should a lot of women want to talk about
their career their bag should we put in
my bag on here absolutely not and I
don't care about that oh no back okay
just double checking yeah no
okay what else what else
um well since we are talking about the
bag I would talk about uh your ability
to manage money stick within a budget
manage money that's a good one no we
have never come up with that one yeah
it's important I mean if you want um it
depends on the type of marriage that
you're going to have and we talk about
this a lot you need to know the type of
wife that you want to be and you need to
know the type of marriage that you want
to have because there are different
kinds you know sometimes people get
married if it's a political figure and
he just needs someone to look good on
his arm or somebody could get married
for papers if there's any kind of legal
situation but in most traditional
marriages if you have a breadwinner
which is usually the husband but it
could be different if you are going to
be in the role of the wife or the
support system you are not the bread
winner which means you have to be able
to work within the income that is
allotted for the family ability we're
going to do types of marriages after
this okay this is so interesting okay so
ability to manage money or stick to a
budget what else I would talk about uh
relationships family relationships like
your family of origin I think that's
really important because when you marry
you're not just marrying the person
you're really combining two families
because that's how it's been for you
know hundreds and thousands of years
you're really bringing two families
together
what what would you like what do they
need to know about I would want to know
the status of your family of origin you
know were your parents married what kind
of example did you see growing up of
relationships if your parents are not
together is it amicable
um do you have a small nuclear family do
you come from a big nuclear family all
of that comes into play because that is
what's going to set your expectations
for either what you want or you don't
want wow that's true because I feel like
the way I look at things sometimes from
like a big family point of view yeah so
like when people I'm just thinking of I
know not everyone goes on vacation but
that was a big part of my childhood like
every summer boot's been a month to go
on vacation and the thought of just
taking two kids and like flying
somewhere was unheard of to us yeah
absolutely and for me it's the complete
opposite so uh when we were planning for
children my ex-husband now at the time
we both come from families with two
children so it's me and my brother and
it's him and his brother and so I'm a
boy mom times two and so after I gave
him two sons we talked about and I asked
him if he wanted to try for a third but
because we were used to that family of
four he said this is enough so we
stopped but I know you often talk about
having that big family experience so for
me it's kind of foreign every time I
hear you say I have nine siblings it's
like who does that does that but it
matters so what else would you say
should go on the wife like what what
should you think about when looking for
a husband or
yeah I mean this is kind of a
comprehensive like what are what are
other things to think about for the
women if we want to look for husbands
okay so well I would switch that we
don't look for husbands we are found by
husbands so we present ourselves as wife
ready
um I would say since you mentioned the
bag if you do want to work what is the
plan for that is it going to be part
time is it going to be a work from home
are you going to have to travel commute
is it something you can do you know
maybe once a week or once a month just
to keep your license so if you are going
to work what does that look like and how
does it support the family oh if you are
going to work what does that look like
because you tell well you tell them what
you told me about how you worked and
like also had a more traditional
relationship yeah absolutely so I've
been corporate since College I work in
technology so I work for a software
company and so it's a you know uh
competitive masculine environment and I
admittedly got caught up in that Modern
Woman mindset and what happens literally
I hit the wall and we talked about this
yesterday when you're in your 20s you
really can't see your 40s but now that
I'm in my 40s I can see 60 really really
easy and I don't want to do 20 something
more years of that so you know like a
lot of women I had the two hour commute
I was going for the promotion everybody
two-hour commute wow that must have been
a long day it was an incredibly long day
but when you don't think that there's
anything odd about that you just get in
line with everybody else and March
towards the um March towards that
routine so what ended up happening for
me like a lot of people with the
pandemic think I was able to work from
home and it was kind of like we're going
to try this out for a few weeks and I
ended up loving it I was able to cook
more and eat better get the weight off I
was less stressed I was sleeping better
and I was just a better mom overall and
you know happier in my relationship so
you know long story short uh now I work
remote and I'm never going back to the
office
foreign
[Music]
a week with your family yeah exactly but
you probably weren't even thinking about
that you're just thinking about it's
like what you're supposed to do
absolutely because I mean let's face it
and Corporate America is great I've
worked for some really big companies but
they like to get us when we're young and
kind of extract all that energy and that
you know intellectual capital and you
end up putting all of your best efforts
towards a company who could either
restructure or be absorbed or say thanks
you know you've aged out anything could
happen so just being mindful of that
it's great when you can get it the
promotions the bonuses all of that and I
still work but I do it in a way that
serves me and like I told you yesterday
I am known to tell my you know my boss
my work is what I do it's not who I am
so what else should we present to the
well I
for sale since you have had some whale
attacks
um that our fitness Fitness yeah okay
it's huge and we can't deny that you're
in shape yeah and what is your Fitness
routine exactly
this routine yeah I'd love to know what
other people think or what you think I
think these are great I think some of
these I've never even thought of before
um
like the ability to manage money or
stick to I've always I've never been a
huge spender to be honest I've been
other than Ubers I really like ubering
grocery delivery
cheap here to be honest I use it too I
love it yeah
um let's see the comments say can you
take constructive criticism oh that's a
good one that's a good one feedback how
how do you handle
constructive
criticism and that one kind of goes back
Pearl to what we talked about with your
nuclear family when you grow up with a
strong father you all know well maybe
you all don't know but I am an immigrant
born in Ghana raised in the South so I'm
an Atlanta girl but I am used to getting
direction very bluntly and then maybe
you go cry in the corner but you get
yourself together and you move on it's
not the end of the world and so if you
don't have that and you've been coddled
and you haven't had siblings that you've
had to kind of you know
um compete with in a way you get
feedback as an adult and it can destroy
you and that is not helpful in a
relationship that's the one thing I
think volleyball really helped me with
is like you can just you can take
criticism so easily because you're just
so like if you don't take the criticism
you're riding the bench absolutely I
think sports are great and I told you
this yesterday I think my guy says it
all the time I think all girls should
play a sport because it gets you in that
state of mind where it's like okay I'm
not good enough up in this area I need
to work on it and that is a skill I saw
that with you yesterday with the cooking
we poached the eggs and you did four of
them and if it wasn't right he said I'm
gonna get that right I want to try again
and I could tell that's the athlete in
you so it's a good quality
I'm gonna read the next one okay
um I love this mentoring collaboration
how do you use recruiters
um go through
go through my following
um find on Instagram
there's one named Jordan and there's one
that's like
if you put in recruiting I think it'll
come up
um
would you come on our platform it
reaches about 10 I mean it depends on
you can email me just pearlythings
gmail.com
um
having a woman that won't bleed you dry
and keep your neck up in debt is
important absolutely that's the one
thing like a lot of girls their
lifestyle is so like a lot of my friends
it's it's like I make more money than
them but they live like such an
expensive lifestyle like they all have
fake long nails like which which are
they they add up it's like 200 like
they'll go to nice places it's 200 bucks
every time they go roughly or 150 to 200
because they're Nails in there and then
on top of that like if they get lash
extensions if they get BOTOX if they get
friends your age are getting Botox
um these are more girls I can just tell
on the show that they've had it the girl
the girls my age don't Botox not yet but
I there's yeah it's a shame Botox lip
fillers like yeah it fake hair oh don't
even think yeah and it's just like
maintain that because it's like unless
you do really well which what percent of
girls are gonna get the opportunity to
be with a guy that does really really
what some will but it's not the majority
so the majority are gonna have to date
and I don't want to say have to like
it's a bad thing like the majority will
date average man and marry average men
if they get married at all so
how are you gonna afford that with kids
you can't first of all it's fake and
second of all the men don't like that
you know men want you they want to know
what they're going to they want to see
you in every environment you know can
you swim can you you know get in the the
carpool can you you know be active all
of that is an expense and a lot of times
you know women we do that for each other
I shouldn't say we but you know you want
to present yourself well but you want to
do it in a way that's sustainable what
men value I've heard you all can chime
in is consistency and the problem with a
lot of that elaborate put on first of
all they don't like it but it requires
so much maintenance and then you go from
looking like you're going on the runway
to who shot John so you know find a
routine that works for you and make sure
that you know number one your man likes
it because ultimately I don't care how
many compliments I get from women if my
man says I don't like your hair like
that I don't do my hair like that
because ultimately his opinion trumps
you know what everybody else would say
and that's like
that's like that is very much like him
before me which is you know how it
should be but it's not common nowadays
yeah and I understand you know and I
kind of got caught up in that you know
thinking it was a partnership but the
problem is and I told you this yesterday
and especially at my age at 47 it
happened after two kids at 35 40 you
really feel yourself as a woman like
okay you know what I kind of want to
slow it down I want to set it down and I
was one of those in my 20s I thought I
could do everything a man could do
compare that to the men that I know at
my age they are putting it in second
gear they're starting businesses they're
investing they kind of have this like
I'm running out of time I want to go
hard so
I you know how you say
women shouldn't vote because they don't
have to go to war
so for me it's kind of the same thing if
I am not going to carry the same load
until 65. oh I should submit because
he's willing to do what I'm not that's
so true because
I never that is such a good point
because a lot of times girls will say
well I make more than him now
yeah or or I out earn him how could I
submit but at the end of the day they're
gonna work longer than us absolutely I
mean if you look at it I know we like to
idolize some women that have it but how
many older women do you know are still
going just as hard in their 50s and
think about that right I really that is
such a good point so even the ones that
we admire you know I don't want to drop
any names you all know the ones that are
really really
um well to do they start stepping back
in their own way but if you look at the
men that are really wealthy you know
they are opening new businesses and you
know acquiring more things and so that
is I feel like the value that having the
older women speak to the younger women
it's like I see myself in you but I also
see you know Maggie at 60 and I'm making
decisions now that it's going to make
that period of time a joyous one oh my
gosh that reminds me of my dad because
he retired he sold his business and he's
just starting a new one exactly it's
like they exactly how many men do you
know that retire from their job I told
you about my dad yesterday and they stay
at home for a few months and they just
like they got Cabin Fever they can't do
it my dad's a retired teacher a PhD he's
a you know retired teacher and he stayed
at home for a little bit as many of you
know you have just banned on Tick Tock
and we are demonetized on a daily basis
on this platform if you want to help
please consider sending a super thanks
below every donation helps and it helps
make what we do possible